I'll let you
know all right it shows that we are live
Ashton Forbes thank you so much for
coming on my show today there's been
major developments uh to people who
aren't aware over the last number of
months especially last few weeks you
brought attention to these videos going
around showing what may be MH370
surrounded by orbs essentially
disappearing as in some sort of a alien
UFO Abduction and I've never seen a
topic go so viral that was so divided
where you have half the people watching
this and saying this is absolutely real
and the other half saying this is
absolutely false and then you have done
such a deep dive into this and brought
some really profound questions about it
it's like is this real is it not and
because of it you got a huge huge
conversation going which makes me very
excited for you because you really you
know you pursued something that was a
legitimate mystery on a topic that the
mainstream media is not going to discuss
and and you got millions of people
talking about in the process so there's
been some major developments I want to
kind of give you the floor to chat about
who you are what this whole situation
was about and and where it stands now
and where it goes from here yeah well
thanks Jimmy first of all for having me
on your dant platform I I appreciate it
and talking about the case I still love
talking about the case and everything
related to it because I think it is one
of the greatest mysteries of all time
you know what happened to
MH370 uh I'm just a normal person put
into an extraordinary situation I like
to repeat that a lot this was probably
the first ever community-led
investigation into a potential
conspiracy that started from the
community from social media and then
morphed into this giant uh wave that's
been out there of attention and uh I
guess divided opinions in terms of you
know what really happened to this plane
are the videos real you know is this
type of Technology real and I just want
to say that I'm very proud of everybody
who has been putting in the work
investigating the videos investigating
the technology around them and the
conspiracy angle I think that we have
accomplished something that that I don't
think anybody expected would be possible
and uh it's been a great to just meet
with people that I had never thought I
would ever talk to in my whole life uh
you know people like kim.com who I
highly respect you know people like you
and the other podcasters that I've been
able to talk to so it's just been a
really great journey and I'm really
excited for you know what comes next
absolutely and I will say that uh
something that's so special about this
is that we live in a time where there's
so much negativity there's so many
things in the media that makes people
very upset like polarizing topics such
as what happening in Israel with Hamas
Palestine um and then to me I'm like the
topic of UFOs is fun um to me it's
harmless uh by and large I guess unless
we're being controlled by aliens right
now which we might
be um and so like to me it's like it was
such a a profoundly a net win to have
pursued a topic that is so mysterious
that has people wondering like how the
hell has it been nearly 10 years after
the mysterious disappearance of 370
virtually Without a Trace assuming that
that that flap found off the coast of
was it Madagascar assuming that that's
legitimate I don't you know I only know
what island yeah yeah um so okay so tell
us where it stands now and maybe because
some people might be hearing this for
the first time maybe give a quick back
brief on what this video showed and you
by the way you can add uh you can
present on here you can show the video
clips um and so people can see and and
then the part and I did share this with
you ahead of time that when I first saw
the video I thought the I thought I'm
like okay this is video of a trip 7 but
I thought the orbs look fake and I
didn't I was like I'll let the internet
do their own research I never did a deep
dive um but the part that was so bizarre
to me was the fact that this video was
mysteriously uploaded a few days after
The Disappearance of
MH370 yeah and it's not titled with it
and it had kind of like these Hallmark
signatures of like is this a
whistleblower that like dump this to the
internet and here it is you found it
years later so I'll let you go ahead and
explain kind of what's going on
yeah so uh and I was just like you
honestly so even back in 2014 I saw this
video that's on the left here which is
our mq1 C greaty Eagle video and back
then you know I just immediately blew it
off I didn't even wasn't into uaps or
anything like that at all back then so I
just thought okay this has got to be
some fake video that was created out
there and you know as I've always said I
think that is only until 2023 where we
could even begin to understand this
footage potentially is even being real
and that's probably why it reemerged and
why there was such a huge discussion
around it is that we see these orbs come
in here and these look like what you
would imagine UFOs you know alien ships
to look like but the more we dug into
this we thought well you know these orbs
are actually we see this non-radiating
barrier around them this uh electric of
this field you know this isn't like a
saucer or anything that we would expect
from the UFO um kind of community that
we might see out there and we see these
trails that are in front of them which
is something you never really had seen I
don't think in the UFO phenomenon or
anywhere but that seem to represent this
geodesic this gravity well being uh
pushed in front of them and this is
where we start to think that okay well
maybe we're looking at Advanced
Technology here and when we're looking
at it in the satellite video as well we
see this pattern being formed around the
plane here and this is where you almost
need to have an understanding of what AI
is capable of to really even think about
how could this pattern even exist right
it looks like it's a computer program
that's being run it's not little aliens
inside these orbs that are flying them
around right this is a situation where
someone has remote controlled something
or you know if you believe the videos
are fake then that this is something
that was programmed in is a perfect 120
degre Z Point sydal pattern into the
videos um not a situation where
someone's flying it's far too exact it
looks like there's some kind of purpose
that's getting ready for this plane here
and we can even see that the pattern
changes and now we see this pattern
change where it's completely vertical
like a vertical ring here and then as it
approaches our uh zap point we can see
this zap go off which accurately
illuminates these clouds in the thermal
here we can see that it um has this cold
event that happens and I'm going to go
to the slow-mo version of this where you
can see that these orbs Converge on the
plane so a lot of these details are so
specific that it really makes you wonder
could these who would have faked these
and how would they have even come up
with the idea of what this stuff should
look like like right and this is what I
think brought the whole conversation of
okay well you know is what we're looking
at then real here and how do we explain
it and so you know even today now I I
just put out a statement you know saying
that we can't say that these videos are
authentic anymore because we have seen
some pictures that have clouds that are
essentially exactly the same as what we
see in that satellite video um but I
would still say that we need to be
looking into this type of technology and
this type of understanding of what you
know if we do think that non human
intelligence is visiting us like how are
they getting here right are they really
getting here in rocket ships are they
floating their way over here after 40 or
50 years or are they using something
else that we can't understand something
similar to what we see in these videos
here that can move faster than the speed
of light faster than the camera can even
pick up um and so I think that's the
beauty of these videos is they they
start to have us ask these questions um
about what all this stuff means so tell
me about your statement tell me about
what kim.com and to people who aren't
familiar so there is this
$150,000 reward trying to encourage
whoever the hoaxer would be because it's
like okay if these videos are fake hey
we'll give you 150 Grand people raise
money kim.com and like let's find out
the answer and so as of right now where
do things stand today based on what came
out because a lot of people um I had
this Market as like a major update and a
lot of people haven't read your
statement they haven't seen kim.com put
out so maybe you could kind of run that
down yeah so I talked with kim.com
earlier today there was last last night
a uh debunk that came out claiming that
they had found this stock footage
related to the satellite pictures that
has a bunch of the clouds in it may even
have the um actual path of the plane and
these pictures of these clouds and then
uh someone came out I'm not going to
name them just because we're on a big
podcast but someone came out saying that
this was uh their their pictures that
they took while they were uh flying to
Japan in 2012 and that they believed
that this uh our satellite video had
come from those pictures I ended up
talking to that person don't have any
reason to believe that they are you know
scop disinformation or anything like
that they seem like a normal person um
and so you know I talked to kim.com
about it and he said that you know he
thinks that this is enough to debunk the
footage however it doesn't technically
meet the criteria that we had set out
for the Bounty which was to provide the
source material as well as the hoaxer
along with it um so from that
perspective you know I had to just I had
to agree with him and that you know as a
logical as a rational person like can't
come up with any reason for why these
pictures are you know these clouds are
exactly the same as the clouds that were
seeing in the footage especially so many
of them out there um and so to me I
think this casts a lot of Doubt on the
authenticity of at least the satellite
footage that's out there um and I think
a lot of people that might be
disappointed in me in these statements
I'm saying will say okay well what about
the other footage you know like what
about the fact that the clouds line up
between them and we've shown these other
effects and I would say okay you know
this doesn't end the conversation but it
definitely cast a lot of Doubt pours a
lot of water over it as well and so this
is why I said that you know this is this
is a good point where we can level set
where we can say okay look at what we've
still accomplished with this look at all
the stuff that we've uncovered from the
conspiracy angle I would still go ahead
and argue that we still have potentially
one of the best stories that fits the
most amount of evidence that's out there
right now and I don't think we would
have a been able to uncover any of this
without these footage being out there
right the whole lithium ion battery fire
and the satellites I was even telling
kim.com the cber system like we pretty
much uncovered that the government is
filming us 247 globally Rel because of
these videos right and on top of it so I
mean there's been other big YouTubers uh
cor uh Corridor Digital came out um so
you you got all these people Reddit
people all over the Internet trying to
decipher is this really or is this is
this not and I want to say good on you
for now seeing because you said this
I've seen you on other podcast where
people are trying to debunk you and
there's been at the time there was some
arguments made that I'm like well you
know and you had pointed out like well
that does not refute this now enough
information has come out to where it's
like you're because you said this time
and time again like until I can see that
this has been refuted I'm not you know
I'm G to keep pursuing it so now it
looks like okay there's enough reason to
see that like okay these there's enough
doubt that these videos are not
authentic um and so good on you for
saying that but I'm like I'm with you
like this is a a net win you got
millions of people talking about
something fascinating and a lot of
things were learned in the process just
like you said that going back to was it
2013 that this went down or 2014 201
yeah and so it's like at that time the
cber system can you explain a little bit
what that is and what because you just
there's tons of light that you just
brought to this which is significant
yeah because it's pretty amazing like we
were looking for all the satellites that
could have taken these videos and so
then we find this satellite pair USA 229
first of all it was in the wrong spot we
were going with the official narratives
thinking oh it must be in the South
Indian Ocean but it was there like hours
too early and then we find out oh well
it's actually in the right spot looking
right down at the location where the
official narrative has the plane turning
into the South Indian Ocean exactly at
1840 UTC and then people would cast a
lot of Doubt on it which might be
correct in hindsight but they would say
that you know these satellites are
moving too fast you can't have a
satellite where you have this perfect
clear image that's out there um and so
then we started saying okay well let's
see if we can explain that and then I
don't even exactly remember how we found
it but if you just Google cbers and you
go to the videos and I'll just share it
because this video is just incredible
honest hly um you go to cbers and just
you go to the videos tab in Google and
you find this video from locky Martin
right at the top I just sitting here
thinking looking at this video going
what the heck they're scanning the whole
world in infrared like we've got these
satellites on the outskirts here these
are your uh geostationary satellites to
stay put and then you have these
Millennia orbit satellites these are
these oblong ones here which are your
relay satellites that can send
communication between assets on the
ground between other satellites that are
out there and then we don't see them
here but you would have your low earth
orbit satellites as well which are going
to be very close to the planet here
they're about 40 times closer than these
ones that are your geostationary further
out and if I fast forward this oh go
ahead I was just gonna ask how many
miles from the further ones out to the
closest ones just out of curiosity so
the furthest ones here are 40,000
kilometers I'm not great at convert into
miles when we're dealing with metric
system but 40,000 kmers down here and
then the ones that you're going to be
your low earth orbits like USA 229 are
only th000 kilometers out so they're 40
times closer so the lower orbit ones are
very close and then these other ones
just stay put out here these
geostationary satellites so that's
closer to 25,000 miles for the furthest
ones and six a little over 600 miles for
the closer ones oh there we go I's see
we're good at math I Googled it but um I
mean the the International Space Station
I believe is only what 300 miles
something like that yeah something like
that it's like yeah it's like half the
distance I think from the uh satellites
the low earth orbit satellites which is
why when you look at those images of it
looks like the Earth's moving really
quickly underneath because it's it's
twice as close as even the low earth
orbit ones and again you can just see
like full scanning happening here so
what we were able to deduce is that you
could just create a computer program
like Google Earth but for video right
and the military most likely uses this
to be able to not just have real-time
video playback of the entire world but
also have it recorded So that you can
just play back any location you want by
you know essentially pulling up a Google
Earth and just putting your access in
and figure out whatever you want to see
and I love this quote here at the End by
locki Martin we never forget who we're
working for like okay that's just
ominous to me but um can you bring that
back up yeah yeah I like to add seen
this I like to add hail Hydra at the end
like what what is this we never forget
who we're working for like what kind of
quote is that like that's just a direct
nod to the US military right um so I
mean this reminds me of like the Google
how they removed their uh their motto
which was don't be evil and then they
REM it it's it's like just like that I
wouldn't be surprised if like Loy Martin
just like wipes that out from after all
the attention we've given I can't even
believe that they even have that
available like I'm just looking at this
going how is this all publicly available
that just goes to the investigation
where everything we've unveiled has been
publicly available information like it's
no secret I've told people I have a
security clearance related to my normal
job I do have a normal job aside from
this and you know it's important to say
that okay everything we've been
disclosing publicly available
information because I I didn't want to
lose that security clearance um but yeah
like that's the most incredible part
about this I think is that how much
information is just out there that we
just didn't even know about like I don't
think this whole cber system would have
ever been even covered without this
investigation and you know that was
another thing that kim.com highlighted
pretty significantly that a lot of
people just you know they can't believe
that we have that level of
sophistication and that level of uh
monitoring from our government yeah so
two questions one what's your position
with the security clearance just out of
curiosity um yeah I work in healthcare
it so my security clearance has nothing
to do with UAP it's not like I work for
locky Martin or uh anything like that um
yeah and I can't go into much detail of
it because I just I don't have a media
clearance related to it but I can say
that I'm not like hiding any secret
information that I would know about or
anything related to anything that we
were investigating related to the videos
so with this cber system do you do we
know what the purpose of it is like what
are the what's what are they searching
for what are they scanning for yeah so
when you first listen to it it says
Global uh persistent surveillance
monitoring which is another indication
that they just have video playback
because it's globally persistent
surveillance monitoring but uh there's
several different purposes one of them
is actually tracking uh missiles is the
one of the big ones and that replaced
the old DSP system as part of our
investigation we found this out as well
which I think was defense space program
so the idea is if somebody lifts a
missile off you can find it you can
track it who knows maybe you can send
some orbs on it and you can uh
annihilate
right um the other benefits though are
actually tracking boats and planes um
some of these spy planes we looked into
actually I think can track submarines as
well so I'm not sure if the infrared can
you know go through the water or what
they do with that we don't have any
examples of anything like that but then
the other two purposes are going to be
for intelligence purposes so again like
spying on people and then Battlefield
awareness that's the other clue as well
Battlefield awareness that okay you know
maybe we're looking at this battlefield
awareness map where you can just like
play out okay where are all the assets
like you're playing a big game of Risk
or something right and you're like okay
move my guy here move your guys there
Etc yeah so real quick I'm looking at
the comments and a lot of people like
okay clearly fake but a lot of I'm
seeing a lot of comments with people
asking well where is it debunk can you
bring up the the the cloud uh images
that led uh to the kind of conclusion
like okay this is leaning towards let's
see I don't actually have it ready right
now to be honest with you it just had
happened so early today but you can guys
can go on Reddit I'm sure it's really
easy to find that are out there um as
well as everywhere on Twitter and so if
you go out there you can find the images
that people have overlaid over the
satellite uh uh video and you can see
that there's a number of clouds that
line up essentially perfectly I looked
myself on the raw images and I found
several the same clouds because I just
wanted to make sure are they now I can't
speak to some of the uh uh compilation
videos that have been put together
whether or not you know I haven't looked
through all of them honestly this just
came out like last last night so I
haven't had all that much time to dig it
up and look at them but one of the
videos that I saw as well looked like it
was almost the whole flight path where
it had been superimposed the the same
clouds throughout it but in my mind even
just a few of the clouds really being
exact matches is it's hard to explain
away like why why are these clouds
exactly the same and I thought okay well
you know maybe there's clouds out there
that you know they all can look similar
stuff like that but so many of them with
like the same images is uh you know it's
a little bit beyond my own belief the
only thing I could come up with if
you're really digging into the
conspiracy angle would be you know did
somebody take these from the video and
then post them out there but we looked
into that and um there's at least some
evidence that the XF data says that
these pictures date back to 2012 the
person I spoke to uh said that they took
them in 2012 so I'm not the kind of
person that's going to try to tear
somebody down who I don't have any
reason to believe that they're lying to
me or anything like that
um so unless there were some evidence
that would come out in the future that
says that somehow this was all a big
deception then to me I think it's pretty
Rock Solid that it's it's too
unavoidable that this stuff is all a big
coincidence you know I think that there
has to be something there now again to
your point you know just technically
speaking the criteria for the Bounty was
not met you know I've been very clear
that the criteria for that Bounty is
that the hoaxer needs to come forward
the hoaxer needs to bring the source
files because just having some pictures
is not enough for to prove that they put
it all together and what have you it
just it cast a lot of Doubt as to
authenticity of the videos in general so
if that person were to come forward I
would uh go ahead and honor my agreement
and I would I would have to check in and
make sure the other people were still
fine but I imagine they would also be
fine with honoring their agreement of
paying the Bounty you know it's like
whose YouTube channel is this so this is
the part that's so bizarre and going
back earlier to what we were mentioning
is that this was how many days after The
Disappearance of 370 was it that this
video was uploaded mysteriously to some
YouTube channel with nothing else on it
yeah they register a non account so the
description says March 12th received
March 12th 2014 now a lot of people run
with that but I've always been very
clear that that's you know we don't know
what that description means when they
say received is that something they just
added in there or is that a situation
where they uploaded it but they didn't
publish it so the publish date says uh
March or May 19th 2014 which is around
72 days after the plane disappeared
which makes it have a bit more of a wind
right so if somebody hoax these they
have between 4 days and 72 days I think
a lot of the people that say that
they're fake would say that well you
know reeside andan must have been in on
it maybe reeside and nonan bought these
pictures from uh whatever website it was
I can't remember where they said they
found them um and then and began to
create them I still think it's quite a
huge list of requirements in order to
fake these uh you know if I if you
really force me like say hey Ashton who
who do you think fake these then given
your newest update I would say that this
almost has to be some type of uh scop in
terms of the government or a state uh
State actor putting them together for
whatever reason just because so much of
the information is like classified
information military
assets um and and then just the amount
of effort it would take to put together
as well in such a small time frame you
know I think that a lot of people
overestimate their skills um and a lot
of people who have been you know VFX
experts who say oh I could have done
this in an hour or four hours it's like
I have a normal yeah I have a normal uh
job too where I do the same thing and
I'll be like hey I'll get this turned
around to you tomorrow right but then
turns out it's like next week I'm I'm
still working on it right so yeah I
think that it's um there's still a lot
of mystery here related to the case um
but you know I just I want to make sure
that I'm an open and honest person about
my opinions and and what I think the
evidence is leading I even get Point
dude and again good on you because this
has been such a divisive topic and you
made it clear like so you believe you
know you had reason to believe that
these were uh authentic videos or at
least you were going to pursue to verify
that they were and you made it clear
when other people like in various
podcasts you know were challenging on it
it's like not until I can actually this
isn't enough to convince me that it's
not now with what's come forward today
you're willing to say okay this is you
know with all these details that have
have come to light we can go with that
it's probably not authentic and good on
you for saying that because you made it
clear you had an open mind but you know
to you know to defend you uh you got to
believe in something to give something
your best investigative effort that's
how it works for me um I was telling you
Offline that one of the things that we
share in common is that we've both been
proponents of controversial or at least
highly debated topics for example I have
a a theory that the ey of Africa or I of
Sahara known as the rot structure is the
most likely location for lost ancient
capital city of Atlantis and although I
would say that many people uh support
that theory there's certainly a sizable
percentage of people that don't and one
of the things that I've experienced is
that some of the reput uh you know
people trying to refute it some of the
examples that they've given I'm like
well this actually doesn't refute it
like this is in some examples actually
supports it so I I know what it's like
to be in your shoes where it's like you
have something you believe in people
challenge you on it and I'm like this
doesn't debunk it like yes I do think
it's by far the most likely location for
Atlantis but I could also agree like
well if it's not like you know show me I
need to understand that it's not before
you know and and and my point that I'm
going with this is that this is the
mentality that's required in order to
find the truth uh so I think you should
be very proud of yourself for bringing a
topic that's so interesting and
debatable to the internet because right
you know it's a positive topic you know
for people to get mad on whether a UFO
video is real or not is not the worst
thing in the world for all the things
that we have in our daily lives right so
um I have to say that your investigative
work is profound uh you're you're really
good deep diver you're an excellent
articulate speaker and I think this is
your calling I think you need to be a
full-time investigative uh worker and I
also think if I may say that I'm like
the reality is that this plane is still
missing which is so freaking weird um in
a few minutes we'll carry this
conversation over to rumble where I
think we should dive into what you think
is the most likely reason for The
Disappearance I'll share my own um let
me see if like on YouTube if anyone has
any super chats of any kind if anyone
has a question
directly while you're doing that too I
would just say as well like I think that
what you mentioned too is that you know
we should be critical thinkers but we
should also stand by our opinions until
we have some solid evidence not to
believe them right i' actually heard of
your uh your opinion in terms of like
the lity of Atlantis and I think that
I've always been open-minded to you know
any stuff like that like I just want to
hear the evidence and hear way out and I
don't think we should succumb to peer
pressure just because people say oh well
this is what the experts say or whatever
so I hope that's a lesson that people
learn in general I still stand by all
the opinions that made in the past and
the evidence that we've put forth for
sure right and and this is something
that we've experienced and why we I mean
everyone on Earth in the last few years
which is that you had a minority of
people pushing back on certain topics uh
as we could all imagine and they were
the minority and turned out to be true
in the long run and so when you talk
about like not succumbing to peer
pressure it's like yeah people have to
have a backbone like if you believe
something you know take it head on um
and there's something I I think very
admirable that is because most people
and I don't mean this to be disparaging
but most people are weak in that if they
have enough people team up on them
they'll just submit um and
understandably because it's tough um to
get you know piled on um but it's
interesting I am looking at these
comments there's a whole lot of people
that are not convinced that this is
debunked uh which is quite interesting
um yeah so let me ask you this when did
you first learn about this uploaded
video to YouTube how long ago was it
that you came across this this was back
on already I think on August 7th or 8th
I think it depends on what time zone but
it actually originated on the social
media site you're probably familiar with
Reddit uh UFO subreddit out there and it
was about like oh I think 10 or 11 days
before the VFX debunk which ended up
falling apart um censored it from the
readit entirely um I think it was
interesting that I think the one of the
first post that's been back allowed on
the subreddit UFOs was the one that was
debunking it again they actually had
banned
uh all discussion of the videos on that
subreddit until just I guess yesterday
um and you know I saw the videos there
and like I mentioned early on I had seen
one of these videos back in 2014 I had
no idea that it even could be real back
then and since 2017 I've seen I don't
know thousands of videos never seen any
that were as compelling as these videos
are I mean two videos showing the same
event uh that are both from military
assets you know these are kind of like
the gold standard when it comes to
ufology and UFO videos we're not talking
about blurry uh Starling satellites and
all this other stuff that people claim
out there you know these aren't Chinese
lanterns that we're looking at or uh you
know the various other excuses that
people give out there so uh that's what
really I think made this stuff
compelling and the case compelling uh
especially early on some of the very
strongest evidence of the mouse over a
citric session uh from the satellite
video the satellite video being cropped
and the Drone being cropped out of view
you know uh a lot of the evidence that
was put forth there really uh led the
investigation to where it is today and
and kind of how it's
been nice um real quick I just updated
let's see if I can pin this replace
message I just updated my uh description
to include the link to rumble and I also
just did it as a pin comment in the chat
because I think here in a minute we'll
just head over to rumble everyone
listening the reason why I go to rumble
is for a variety of reasons involving
free speech and anti-censorship
um and so I'm trying to grow over there
for for very important reasons I
wouldn't be doing it if it wasn't
otherwise I will mention to people real
quick is that I my following on Rumble
is a fraction of what it is on YouTube
yet I'm getting more views on Rumble
think about that I will also mention
real quick that I'm working on a few
videos a lot of people are more into my
typical presentations so I have a few
killer topics that I'm working on so yes
new videos are coming but in the
meantime I do encourage people to follow
me over to rumble it doesn't you don't
have to you know it's so funny people
like I'm going anywhere it's like you
just got to click or type in Ru MBL e on
you know on it's like I'm not asking you
to walk down the mile to buy me a a
gallon of milk here just click the link
it's really easy and I wouldn't be
asking for it if it wasn't because
there's a lot of things that have
happened behind the scenes yeah um that
at some point in time I'll share but
like I'm doing this for a reason I can't
have all my eggs in one basket um but
with that being said uh I think I'll at
this time encourage people I don't see
any uh super chats let me double check
here um so I'll tell people that right
now we're streaming simultaneously on
Rumble you can find the link in the
description if you just hit the refresh
because I just added it but it's also in
the link on the pinned comment in the
chat so at this time I'll close it out
on YouTube and then what we'll do is on
Rumble let's dive into what we think the
most likely situation is then with 370
because now we're at the time and in one
of let me just say
this I'm thrilled that you brought in
regardless of these videos being
authentic or not you brought the top the
370 back into the public light because
it had essentially been forgotten for a
bit that we're we're approaching a
decade and it disappeared almost Without
a Trace and it makes it is unbelievable
that that could happen even in 2020 that
we went no where it's at and I have some
thoughts on that I know you do too so at
this time I'd encourage people to go
ahead and just hit the rumble link and
we'll go over and dive into that now
sound good come on over Rumble come over
to rumble guys y all right hit the link
in the descript description if you hit
the refresh button link in the uh pin
comment but I will go ahead and do that
now